after EU leaders reached the landmark
deal to cut greenhouse gas emissions by
forty percent by 2030 at the european
council meeting environment ministers
will continue discussions on further
greening the European semester and the
midterm review of the Europe 2020
strategy that is ensuring that the
macroeconomic policies are sustainable
not only economically and socially but
also environmentally ministers will also
discuss new rules aimed at improving
waste management in the European Union
in order to better protect the
environment and our natural resources in
terms of household waste alone each
European citizen produces on average
half a tonne of such waste a year of
which only forty percent is recycled
I'll go across the EU waste management
continues to improve the European
economy still loses many potential
secondary raw materials such as metals
woods glass paper or plastics turning
waste into a resource is key to achieve
a circular economy finally ministers are
also expected to refine the EU position
for the Lima Climate Change Conference
which will take place from the first to
the twelfth of December in Peru